[MUSIC PLAYING]
REZA ROKNI: Good
morning, everybody.
First of all, thank you
very much for electing
to spend some of your time here
today talking about chatbots,
and BigQuery, and data sources.
My name is Reza Rokni, and I'm
one of the solution architects
here at Google.
Been here over five years,
predominantly out of the UK
office, but recently moved over
to lovely, sunny Singapore.
Part of the solution
architecture role
is to look at new use cases, new
applications of our technology,
work with customers very
closely to actually build out
some, many of our product
pieces, et cetera.
And then, if we
find a good match,
then our next role is to do
things like blogs and solution
papers to scale that out.
One of the best parts of my job
is working with some fantastic
people, like James.
JAMES TROMANS: Thanks, Rez, and
thank you all for being here.
My name's James Tromans.
I work at Citigroup, as
part of the capital markets
FX trading team, where I'm
head of data science there.
And today, we're going to talk
to you a little bit about how
we've combined different Google
technologies to ideally enhance
our client experience for both
internal users of our products,
but external users, as well.
And we'll be building on
technologies like Dialogflow,
BigQuery, and Pub/Sub.
This project originated
probably two years ago,
when Rez and I were doing some
work with Thomson Reuters.
If you're not familiar
with Thomson Reuters,
they're a market data
company, among other things.
And at Citi, we were
interested in consuming
some of that market data--
very large amounts of
it-- through BigQuery,
so that we could
do different types
of mathematical
analytic queries,
visualizations, and
that sort of thing.
And from there,
we decided, well,
wouldn't it be
interesting if we could
do some more unusual
types of ways
to get at that data
and surface insights
for our users in
a different way?
So the first part of this
talk-- is the clicker working?
Great-- is going to discuss
the business goals, and also
some of the constraints within
which we had to work in order
to achieve what we wanted to.
And so I just
thought I'd give you
an indication of the scale
of the foreign exchange
and local markets
business at Citi.
Because that points to some of
the opportunities that we have,
in terms of being
able to reach lots
of customers in
different countries,
but also some of the challenges.
So we have thousands of
clients, from corporate clients
to hedge funds to
real money clients,
and we deal with hundreds of
different types of assets.
We actually have trading
desks, physically,
in 77 different countries,
but obviously, we're
one very large bank.
We deal in about 160 countries
and jurisdictions, overall.
And we actually do about
$4 trillion US dollar
transactions, totally, per day.
So with that scale
comes great opportunity,
but it also brings
some challenges.
As our business has evolved,
electronification is a phrase
that we use to describe the fact
that much more is happening now
through electronic channels,
through APIs, or even
just through chat.
Less is happening through
phone conversations.
And so with that means
we have more data.
We collect more data
than ever before,
both in terms of the market
data that I alluded to earlier,
but also trade data.
And with that, if we want
to do computation on that,
we need more powerful compute.
We need different
types of compute.
We need more storage.
So with electronification
as the backdrop,
we also notice that
our users are becoming
more technologically literate.
So a graduate from 15
years ago who came out
of university, or
10 years ago, who
may have been
using Facebook back
then if he was an early adopter,
or she was an early adopter,
is now the sort of
person that is expecting
more from their technology in
their professional work place,
as well.
What they're
comfortable with at home
they obviously expect at work.
And I think, in many industries,
professional technology
relationships take a
longer time to mature,
in terms of how the users
interact with their technology,
when compared with
their personal.
So we're mindful of
this, and we want
to make sure that we
can provide as good
of an experience in your
professional working
engagement with Citi as you
do with your private ones,
with your other
technology experiences,
like when you work with Gmail.
Now, technology is used to
empower the existing teams
that we have, and I think,
as a data scientist,
I'm always very interested
in how we can use data
and modern machine
learning algorithms
to empower the
people and the staff
to better serve our clients.
So Citi itself produces a
very large amount of data,
and that's probably one of our
largest competitive advantages.
And so we want to make sure that
we provide the right tooling
to our team, so that they can
expose interesting insights
to our clients
when they need to,
on demand, at the
click of a button,
or in a very seamless way.
And we need to be able to
do that in a way that's
going to scale to meet
all of the different types
of customers that we have in
all of the different countries
that we operate.
Now as I mentioned, with
all of the different types
of businesses that
we have, we have
to make sure that
whatever we build now
is going to fit
within our existing
technological infrastructure.
So we have our own
data, as I mentioned.
We have lots of
existing technology,
and we have our own data
centers and our own networks,
all of which
already exist today.
So there's no way that we can
build something that's entirely
cloud native, that
doesn't sit and interwork
with exactly what we already
have working on premise.
So we need to make sure
that whatever we build
is going to work within this.
And that means that
we're going to have
to think about the architecture
of the application,
and how that's going to
fit with what we have.
We'll talk a little
bit about that today.
So it needs to integrate with
existing user interfaces.
We're talking about a chatbot
or a conversational UI.
So we have existing tools that
our own staff and our clients
are already working with, so
we need to keep this in mind.
It's not just about greenfield
projects all the time,
and leaving legacy technical
debt behind with you, as well.
So we've got to make
sure we deal with that.
And ultimately, if we do
choose to go cloud native,
we need to make sure that
whatever we are building today
doesn't need a
rewrite in the future.
So just to frame it
altogether, we're
interested in looking at
conversational user interfaces,
chatbots, to address
all of the challenges
that I just mentioned-- our
scale, the amount of data
that we have, and the way
that technology within finance
is changing, and the way clients
want to interact with us.
We're looking at using data
sets from Thomson Reuters,
but also the data
sets that we have
on premise that are our own.
And we're using technology
like Dialogflow, which we'll
demo you later, Google
BigQuery, and Pub/Sub
to explore how we can build
this conversational UI,
and make it work seamlessly.
So with that I'm going
to hand back to Rez,
and he's going to talk
to you a little bit
about the actual architecture
and the application
that we built.
REZA ROKNI: Yeah.
Thanks, James.
So that last slide of
James' was interesting
because it had quite a
few components in there.
And when we were
planning out our chatbot,
one thing that we rapidly
came to the conclusion of
is that no chatbot is an island.
So while a chatbot--
you can build an experience
just purely as a chatbot,
it's much more powerful
in the application
when we apply it with
other technologies
and other back ends, so being
able to service the things
that the users want
integrated seamlessly
with both stuff in the cloud,
and potentially, on premise.
And for that, what you
need is a platform.
If you define a
platform, it's a group
of technologies that are used
to base other technologies
and applications on top of.
So what we needed was a
platform that could serve all
of our needs around both the
machine learning aspects--
around Dialogflow itself, around
natural language understanding,
et cetera--
but also, getting data
from other sources,
whether that's internal
or within the cloud.
And this is the current
working platform
that we put together
when working with James.
On your right-hand side,
we see some of the systems
where we're drawing
our information from.
So we have BigQuery
as a store of data,
and now BigQuery can support
both the internal system data,
but also the external
data providers,
and we'll go through that
in a little bit more detail.
We wanted to make sure that
we could work with things
like Spanner, if we needed
transactional activity,
and Pub/Sub for that messaging.
But if you notice
the internal systems,
as well, so whatever
we built had
to work with both
of these paradigms.
Also, on your left-hand side--
forgetting my left and right--
we have the user
side of the house.
So this is converting what
a user says into actions.
We use Dialogflow for that.
We used Firebase to actually
get the information that's
been retrieved to the user.
If you notice, we've had this--
we built this SubHub service.
Now, what that hub
does is actually
coordinate and interact all of
these communication channels.
The reason we did that is
because we wanted easy drop in
and out of other components.
So for example,
we used Firebase,
but internally,
within Citi, they
have other systems that
can update clients.
So the system needed
to be able to deal
with two types of things
very easily within any part
of this component architecture.
And actually, looking
towards the future
was other things that we'd
like to add to the platform.
JAMES TROMANS: Sure.
Yeah.
So when we think
about what Dialogflow
is going to be doing
for us, Dialogflow
serves the sit between
the inquiries from a user,
and then what you
actually want to serve
is a fulfillment
request to the user.
And so I'm interested
in saying, OK, we
have all of this
proprietary data.
But we also have a lot of
proprietary algorithms, right?
We're a bank.
And so if I have a user
that's interested in asking
quite a challenging question
that's going to take a Quant
library that we've built
over 15 years to answer,
that's a very much
custom-crafted modeled
approach, which we have on
premise working already.
So we need to integrate the two.
But of course, as
we move forward,
and as we're
already doing today,
we're interested in using
more modern machine learning
algorithms from open
source libraries,
whether that's actually Boost
or Scikit-learn or TensorFlow.
Whatever we're going to service
the request from the client
with, whatever
the inference tool
that we're going
to use to do that,
it needs to work there, as well.
So you've got
completely custom stuff
on premise, a middle ground with
reusing open source technology.
And then, obviously, we'd be
silly not to think forward
to the future, where we might
be using some of Google's
hosted model solutions, so some
of the existing off-the-shelf
managed solutions from a machine
learning perspective, as well.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
So obviously, there's
a lot of technology
that we used in building
out this application--
Containers, BigQuery,
Spanner, Firebase.
We're not going to
have a chance to walk
through all of those things.
There's lots of
great sessions that
have a lot of material on that.
I'm only going to walk
through two components.
One is BigQuery, as one
of our data sources.
And the other one is
obviously Dialogflow itself.
So just a little
bit about BigQuery,
if you're not familiar already.
It's Google's petabyte-scale
data warehouse in the cloud.
Like any data warehouse,
it is ANSI SQL.
It has the ability to
build dashboards or run
ad hoc queries.
It also has a
streaming API, which
means you can actually
upsert streams of information
into BigQuery, and when you make
a call, it's up-to-date data.
And that will come
in useful in a moment
when we show some of the demos.
The other part of it is
fully managed and serverless.
In other words, the bank
doesn't need to set up anything
to make use of it.
So one component, and part of
the architecture for BigQuery,
which was particularly
helpful here,
is this idea of separation
of storage from processing.
Now, what that means,
there's two benefits for you.
So one, in terms of processing,
if you're not running a query,
then you're not paying
for any machines
to be ready for
accepting that query.
But the other benefit is
around sharing of data.
So if you think of a
traditional database,
you have the database
software that you install.
You attached SAN, NAS
disk, et cetera, to that.
Then you load data into it.
Now to share data, you
either have to give access
to the database-- and
I used to be a DBA,
and that's not something
I'd give very easily--
or you need to build
an application layer,
or you need to do the FTP
dance, which is never pretty.
However, because
of this separation,
what you can have is
data stored in a project,
as long as the correct security
and ACLs have been done,
can be shared with
other projects.
So within an internal,
very large organization,
like Citi, if they're
uploading data, they can--
again, with the right
security and ACL levels--
share data amongst themselves.
But also, it allows you to blend
in data from external sources
very easily.
And a very good example
of this is the work
that we did with
Thomson Reuters,
with quite a few banks.
So obviously, Thomson
Reuters have a huge data set
that is available through
their web service APIs.
But for POCs, they
also worked with us
with providing that data
onto BigQuery for the banks
to consume.
And that gives us access to 20
years of historical tick data.
They also do near real time.
So within seconds, they can
do inserts into our database.
And again, the benefit
here is that, once you've
gone through the right
security and the access levels,
there's nothing
else for the bank
to do other than run queries.
What I'm going to do is
just do a quick demo.
We can go over to
the laptop, please.
Thank you.
That is a giant screen.
I better not make any mistakes.
OK.
So this is the new
BigQuery user interface.
I'm not going to run through
all of the capabilities here.
I just wanted to highlight
one particular thing,
and that is that we are
currently in this project--
FX project-- which is the one
I've used to do my develop
and testing with for James.
And within this project,
on the left-hand side,
we can see other projects that
are available because I've
got access to them.
I've been authorized
against them.
So obviously, there's
the project that I'm in.
But further down, we can
see this TR-EMS project.
Now this is a project
that Thomson Reuters own,
and they have given me access to
data sets within that project.
I'm going to just
quickly go down
to one data set, which is
New York Stock Exchange
information.
Here, we have a table.
I'm just going to
select Details.
So this table is five
terabytes and 40 billion rows
of information.
Now, for me to run
a query, I'm going
to run this query on the
top here against that data.
So I'm running this
query in my project.
I haven't moved any data around.
And it's working
against the data
that I've been authorized
against in Thomson Reuters
project.
So that will take
about 25 to 30 seconds.
That particular query,
volume-weighted average price,
you wouldn't normally run
it against all the data.
I'm just doing that to
show that we can do it
against 30 billion rows.
Takes about 25 to 27
seconds to complete.
So there was no need for me to
do my tap dance routine, which
is very good for you.
Here, we see 63
was the result. I'm
going to just show
one other table.
I won't run a query against it.
And that is in
this data set 213,
which has FX currency data.
And just the thing to highlight
from the details, if I
can get my--
move this properly.
This particular table
has a streaming buffer.
What that means is that
Thomson Reuters is currently
pushing data into
this table, and it
is being updated in near
real time, within seconds.
So when a query is run
against that table,
we get live update information.
OK.
So with that, if we could go
back to the slides, please.
So that's one of the data sets
that we're going to be using.
Thank you.
So now, towards Dialogflow.
As I said, I've been
here five years,
and it's really great to see all
the icons popping in, and how
full these charts are becoming.
So out of our Cloud
AI solution set here,
we are going to be
talking about Dialogflow,
which allows us to build
a conversational interface
against--
when users ask for
information, we
can extract information from
the intents that they have.
And one of the nice
things about Dialogflow
is that it is making more
and more use of all the ML
capabilities that we have
built into the product itself.
So natural language
understanding, so we
have sentiment
analysis now within it.
We have speech-to-text.
All of these components
are just coming out
of the box with Dialogflow.
In terms of the use cases that
we are going to talk about,
the one that we predominately
worked with James on
was around the
business to employees.
So this is helping the
traders make decisions.
And we're looking in
the future, potentially,
towards doing stuff
around their customers.
In terms of Dialogflow
itself, and we'll
go through this in a
little bit more detail
when we do the demo,
there is an agent.
You can try and think of
an agent as a NLU module.
It's an encapsulation
of entities, intents,
and contexts.
What an intent is is when a
user provides some information,
like says a sentence,
the intent allows
us to map that
sentence to actions
that we're going to be taking.
What entities do--
so often, when
we want to take an action
against a sentence,
we need to extract information,
and entities allows
us to extract those parameters.
A context gives us where we are
in the conversational space.
So if a user, for
example, has currently
asked for information about
eurodollar currencies,
and then the next
question is give me news,
then we know, because they
were talking about eurodollar,
that that's what they
intend us to go and fetch.
And then we have the
fulfillment service,
which allows us to make calls
to all these other back end
services.
And with that, we're
going to go now
to a demo of the client working
within the Citi environment.
JAMES TROMANS: All right.
So just before I let it run,
I'm going to just orientate
to what you're seeing here.
Hopefully, you can read that.
So on the right-hand
side of the screen,
or I should say the
right 2/3 of the screen,
is an existing internal
application within Citi.
We call it the trader toolkit.
And for the purposes
of this demo,
I produced a simple dashboard,
which comprises two widgets.
One is a chart widget,
which is in the top half,
and the other is a table.
And that table
contains interesting
economic, macroeconomic
events that
are relevant for the particular
asset that's being plotted.
On the left-hand side,
you'll see that we have,
if you're familiar with
Dialogflow already,
an out-of-the-box chat UI.
Now, obviously, you'd integrate
this with your own chat system,
if you were going to embed
this into your product.
So Citi has some of
its own technology,
which this would embed to.
And of course, anything
that offers an API,
this could work with.
So I'm going to set
the demo to play.
So we recorded this
approximately a week
and a half ago, I think.
When did we do it?
The 16th or the 17th.
And so the user on
the left is going
to ask to draw a
chart of euro dollar.
So once they did that,
immediately, in real time--
we haven't sped anything up--
the client application
on the right-hand side
took that information and
was able to change the chart
in the top half of the screen.
And the second, bottom half of
the screen updated, as well.
And so in order
for that to happen,
two things needed
to take place--
the idea of drawing a chart,
this intent, and the entities
needed to be extracted.
In this case, eurodollar, or
the euro dollar exchange rate.
You'll see these circles
on the chart, which
show the relevant
economic events,
and the colors of the circles
depict how important they are,
and the number is
kind of the weight
of how important that event is.
And so the user can now,
interactively, say, OK.
How about dollar yen?
Different currency pair,
the Japanese currency
against the dollar.
And so you'll notice
that they didn't
have to say chart,
or show me something.
It's just very conversational.
It's carried forward
the context of the fact
that the user's
interested in charting.
And it's obviously
understood that it's
extracting a different entity--
in this case, dollar yen.
So the user can now interact
with the application.
They can fiddle around.
They can explore and
do some analysis.
So it's getting slightly
more complex now.
We can do other things.
So we can have other
types of intents.
So the user is now saying,
OK, please scatterplot euro
against yen.
And because the application,
again, is context aware,
it knows that the user
is intending to plot
euro dollar against dollar yen.
So here is an
interactive scatterplot,
the x-axis being euro dollar
and the y-axis being dollar yen.
And some of this
existing functionality
that we have within the
application, the user
can play around and, instead of
plotting just the raw values,
they can plot things
like percentage rank,
and they can change the
lookback windows over which
that's calculated, and so on.
So we've got simple
charting intents.
We've got slightly
more plotting intents
embedded into this application.
But we can go further.
We can do more.
So the next one I
want to show you
is this concept of a
backtesting intent.
So the user is now
going to say, backtest--
what did they do?
Euro dollar after dollar
yen is greater than 110.
So currency rates
obviously have values,
and the user is
interested in knowing
what happens to one currency
when a different currency goes
above a certain value.
And so in order
for this to happen,
we didn't just have to get
the intent and the entities.
We also had to have
this condition.
And so it's brought up
this study of what happens.
And you'll see at the top,
we have this time series,
and the blue dots represent
every time that event occurred.
And in the middle chart, we
have the average price path
up to 24 hours
later, showing you
what's happened to the
euro dollar exchange rate
after the dollar yen has
gone greater than 110.
As you click in, you get the
distribution of returns below.
This is a nice
study for the user
to be able to interact with.
So shifting gears
slightly, moving away
from just controlling
the user interface, what
happens if we actually wanted
to engage with our customers
so that they could
buy something from us?
We have a lot of custom
lingo in finance, which
you'll see some of it now.
So the user is asking to chart
euro, euro against the dollar.
That's the standard
when they say that.
And then they're going
to ask for a price.
So the way in which a
customer or a sales person
may choose to do that
is quite specific.
They say, how wide in 9 million.
So they're interested
in a price that we'd
be willing, as a
bank, to buy to them--
sorry, sell to them,
and buy back from them
9 million eurodollar.
And we only quote the last two
digits of the exchange rate.
We have these conventions.
So we're showing 49 on one
side and 51 on the other.
And the user's saying, mine.
That's lingo for buy.
They want to buy.
So they're interested in
picking one of those prices.
They didn't tell us,
in advance, which one.
They want to buy it, and
so they've said mine,
and we've returned with
transaction complete.
And here's an
example transaction
ID, explaining to them
what they've done.
So following on with
this kind of idea
of having to train up
on different lingo,
we have this concept of cable.
So if you're not
from finance, cable
is the great British
pound against the dollar.
It's a specific terminology
just for that pair.
And so they've
asked to plot that.
And then they're going
to, instead of buy,
this time the user's going to
say, OK, make me 3 million,
a different way of
asking for the price.
Instead of how wide, they've
said make me 3 million.
So we've given back them
a quote specifically
for 3 million cable.
And it's the same price
because we haven't integrated
this with our pricing API, but
that would be the next step.
And then they've said,
done left-hand side,
and that means that they're
interested in selling,
and they've done so.
So the transaction
has completed.
So just to kind of summarize
what's taken place here,
we've controlled the
UI to enable the user
to do some exploratory
data analysis,
look around at charts, look at
the relevant economic events,
do some backtesting.
And then, having
done that analysis,
they've decided that
they wanted to move
into a transactional
business engagement with us.
And we've trained Dialogflow
on very customized,
specific terminology, and we'll
talk a little bit about how
you do that in a minute.
Over to Rez for another demo.
REZA ROKNI: Thank you.
Can you switch to
the laptop, please?
Thank you.
So obviously, I
don't have access
to their internal systems.
So when I'm playing and trying
to explore stuff for James,
we built a sort
of parallel agent.
And I have no talent in
UI, so one of my colleagues
in Singapore built this for us.
In principle, it's the
same kind of thing.
It has a graph of information.
We also have some
news information
underneath that we populate
from Thomson Reuters again.
The data that we've
provided for is--
this is 2015 that we have
access to from Thomson Reuters.
So what I'm going
to do is just show
that this is fairly similar to
the application we had before.
Here, we have
sterling being shown.
So I'm going to do, show me
a graph of a euro dollar.
And when I go back, that
should have changed.
And let's see how
dry my mouth is.
We shall soon find out.
[PHONE DINGS]
Show me a graph
of pound sterling.
[PHONE DINGS]
There you go.
And [PHONE DINGS] show me
news on pound sterling.
[PHONE DINGS]
OK.
So my mouth isn't that dry.
So that actually changed
underneath, as well.
Sorry I didn't have
that highlighted.
That was just Dialogflow.
The same intents
were being used.
We're now using
the speech-to-text
to actually convert what
I was saying into text.
That was being
represented on the graph.
So in terms of
Dialogflow itself--
just to go through a
few pieces before we
do another small demo
around some new features
that have been
added to Dialogflow.
This is the Dialogflow
user interface.
I'm currently in my
FX tester environment,
which is just a play environment
to work around with intents.
For those of you not
familiar with Dialogflow,
we have the idea of intents
to actually convert text
into actions and entities.
What I usually start
with is entities.
In this case, the entities
that we have available
are things that are built
in, including currency.
Now, the currency
entity, Dialogflow
does have a system-built
entity called
Currency that would normally
suffice for any currency
activity.
However, as James
demonstrated, there's
a lot of domain-specific
language that we use here.
And therefore, I built
my own currency entity
so I could overload it with
the domain-specific language
that we need.
For example, if we go
to Australian dollar,
so by doing that,
I've brought up
the entity Australian dollar.
This is the symbol and
these are the synonyms
that are associated with it.
At the end, we
have Aussie as one
of the domain-specific
languages.
GBP-- so I'm going
to add one to this.
So this is Great British pounds.
And where I grew up in
Northolt, we don't actually
refer to pounds as pounds.
Down where I work,
it's quids, mate.
Like two quid for a
pint, showing my age.
It's been a long time since
it was two quid for a pint.
So for that, I'm
going to put quid.
And essentially,
that's all I have
to do to actually teach it that
quid equates to pound sterling.
Now, when I go to do an intent--
so we have various intents.
I'm just going to show
one of the intents, which
is the graph intent,
which you've seen quite
a few times in the demo now.
This graph intent takes
a series of phrases.
I'm going to put one in now.
Show me a graph of
quid versus dollar.
So I just added quid as a
synonym for that entity.
What Dialogflow does
very nicely for me
is, when I type
that sentence in,
it's already figured out that
some of the values that I've
put in are currencies.
It's already highlighted
those for me.
And this is step one of
extracting the parameters
that we need from this intent.
So if I scroll down,
we can actually
see the actions and parameters.
Here, I've defined the
input graph action.
This is call to my code at the
back end to actually invoke
that handler.
We also have some parameters,
so for example, the currency
parameter.
If you notice on
this side, we've
ticked this box under Required.
So if a user says
show me a graph,
and they don't provide
a currency to me,
I don't know what to draw.
So we're going to prompt
them to give us the currency.
And that's all inbuilt
into Dialogflow.
If I click on the prompts,
these are a couple
of the prompts that will
be provided to the user,
as we get them to give us
the currencies that we're
interested in.
If you notice, we've added
more than one prompt.
This is good UI design
for conversations
to make the user feel a little
bit more comfortable with using
the chatbot, if you
give different sentences
for the same questions.
Outside of this piece,
I'm going to just show
a new piece of
functionality that
has been added to Dialogflow.
So I'm going to go to one of
my user environments, so FX.
This is where we've actually
got things wired up.
And one of the things I find
particularly useful when
working and developing
on here is the test
UI that you can use on
the right-hand side.
So here, if I do show me a
graph of yen versus dollar,
what this is doing is we can
see the response that was given.
But much more
interestingly, it gives us
information about
what Dialogflow
extracted from that sentence.
So I can see the action
is correct-- input.graph.
I can see that the
parameter is currency,
and it's picked
out yen US dollar.
We have some extra information,
which is not part of the demo
today.
Also particularly useful
is diagnostic info.
So here, we actually see
all the raw JSON responses
that it is sending to
the back end services.
And this is super useful when
you're doing debug and testing.
Just take the JSON from
there, put it into a message,
and then call your
back end web service.
So the thing I'm
going to show you now
is a little bit of a
different flow from the one
that we saw with James.
So I've got a currency.
Now I'm going to say,
quote me 2 million.
My one is not as
integrated as James's.
So I just say, here's a
quote for 2 million xx yy.
If you notice, however,
there is a sentiment score
attached to it.
This has been built
into Dialogflow.
I think it was just
recently announced.
And this provides a negative
or positive sentiment
to the statement given.
Now, that statement that
I asked, give me a quote,
didn't have any sentiment.
Let's say I was not
happy with that price.
And I'm British, so I'm not
going to swear at the system.
So we're going to say, that's
a terrible, awful price,
which is as strong as I
like to get, being English.
Here, we can actually see
that the response was, oh,
please don't get mad.
Now, obviously, Citi would put
a far more professional response
to that thing.
But the reason it said
that is, if I scroll down,
we have a sentiment
score of 0.9 negative.
Now, if I go to some
of my code to show
how we implemented this,
what we do is that intent--
the handler for that intent--
looks at the sentiment
score for that sentence.
If it goes over a
threshold-- and you'll
notice that the
threshold is quite low.
I've deliberately set that--
it's going to fire a different
response to the user, instead
of sorry we couldn't help you.
Oh, please don't get mad.
Now, the other
thing that it does
is it logs to Pub/Sub,
which is our global publish
and subscribe API, the message
with the negative sentiment.
And what this allows us
to do is to have systems
that can react to if a
customer, for example,
is getting angry at us.
Now, the sentiment
score I showed
you was part of that sentence.
However, you can have an
overall sentiment score
for the whole conversation.
And this starts getting
very, very interesting,
in the kind of things that we
can now do with the chatbot.
The other thing of
integration that we built
was all of the intents
I log to BigQuery.
Now, the results, I'm
just dumping as raw JSON.
BigQuery can extract
JSON information.
So every intent, everything
that's being done,
is being logged.
If I run the query, it
actually will show just
what's at the bottom anyway.
But here, we have the
different intents,
a confidence score
in how confident
we were that that was
the intent the user had,
and the sentiment score
that was associated with it.
Now, the reason
this is interesting
is if we have a mechanism
for Pub/Sub to notify us
something's going wrong,
and we have the history
of the conversation, we can--
JAMES TROMANS: Right, yeah.
So you can imagine,
if you're building
this for your own teams, as I
was thinking about it at Citi.
If you're automatically
serving requests
from customers--
in our case, it's
both internal
users and external.
Especially in the case
of external customers,
you want to be thinking
about, OK, we're
automatically serving them.
But what happens if
something goes wrong?
And it might not
even have gone wrong.
Perhaps just the customer's
dissatisfied with something
when they came to you, even
before the conversation.
And so you may choose to
actually have something
published onto Pub/Sub.
Obviously, that's real time.
And you can surface
an alert to a user--
sorry, a Citi
employee, in my case.
You can actually then field that
request manually and slot back
into the chat and take control.
And by publishing all
of the previous requests
through the
Dialogflow interface,
whether that's your own or
something else, into BigQuery,
you obviously have the history.
So although we didn't
build it for the demo,
you can imagine how
you've been alerted.
You have all the history
of what's come before.
The user can read up,
understand the chat,
and start getting involved in
the conversation very quickly.
So that's obviously
quite an important,
I would say,
prerequisite, as you
start getting into beyond
traditional just FAQs,
and you start doing something
a little more involved.
This would be something
that's quite nice to have,
and now possible.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
Thank you.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
Fantastic.
There we go.
So in terms of the architecture
patterns, there are two types.
There's standard deployment.
So there's a lot of things
that you can do just with
out-of-the-box integrations
with Dialogflow.
That's both on the front
end and the back end.
We're using Firebase functions.
In our example, we used this
very decoupled deployment
because of the
complex environment
[INAUDIBLE] that we're in,
and some hybrid requirements.
So just to cover the
standard architecture,
the out-of-the-box integrations,
a couple of clicks and you get
things integrated.
It takes care of all
the things, like when
a user makes a call
to the front end,
the queries get sent
onto Dialogflow for you.
You have things like, you can
write simple Cloud Functions
to deal with the
fulfillment side of things.
In terms of our architecture, if
we dive into what that actually
means, that flow, let's start
picking this a little bit
apart.
So first of all, the
fulfillment side of the house,
this is a web call.
So now, if you want
to decouple that,
you can just stand up
a RESTful web service,
and absorb these calls,
and give the response
wherever you choose to
stand up your web service.
On the other side of the house--
although we didn't
show it in the demo,
we were using standard client--
it would be important
for the client
to be outside of the
standard integrations.
Because, for example, we
would want the authentication
and authorization for the client
to be done within Citi using
Citi's mechanisms.
And this means we end
up with a typology
where we are going to have the
client be essentially something
that the user builds and
proxies to Dialogflow.
So this is going back to our
complex environment document.
So here, we have
that flow, right?
So we have a user that is--
an application that
can use authentication
and authorization from
within the environment that
exists within Citi.
It can then communicate,
through the hub service,
to all of these other systems.
This is the flowchart
of how this would work.
If you imagine the client is
now a piece of code that's
sitting in a container at
Citi, the user logs in,
they're going to
do authentication
and authorization with the hub.
And the code in the hub,
we put into a container,
which meant it was
easily portable
between our environments.
The authorization, once
done, the hub-- the user
can then start
putting in requests.
That request is sent to the hub.
The hub then takes that request,
piggybacks it onto another HTTP
call over to Dialogflow.
We get the response
from Dialogflow.
The hub can respond
with, we're going
to be creating
the graph for you.
If you imagine a trader
is typing on one screen,
they've got-- and I've
been into those rooms.
They've got tons of screens.
It's really cool.
Then, in the meantime, the
hub will also then do things
like make calls to BigQuery to
extract the tick data that was
available from Thomson Reuters.
Then, once it
receives that data,
we send that information
on to Firebase
to allow the clients
to be updated.
So when I was calling
into Dialogflow,
and you saw the
graph being updated,
that's what we were
using to achieve that.
So, lessons learned.
JAMES TROMANS: Yeah.
So I think, when you're
thinking about using something
like Dialogflow
yourself, I mean,
the architecture that
we've come up with
was something that I asked
Rez to help us with because we
have quite a lockdown network.
We have a lot of existing
constraints and rules
that we have to follow.
And so the hub architecture
really enabled us to work
within those requirements,
whereas out-of-the-box
Dialogflow gives you a
lot of this functionality.
If you're going to be
cloud native already
or it's a completely
greenfield project,
there's a lot you
don't have to build.
So the hub gives
us that flexibility
to take something
that we already have
and move towards
something that's
going to look like production.
Whereas, if you were just
starting this from scratch,
you would be able to
do this more simply.
So you kind of have the
best of both worlds.
When we started
this, in my mind I
had the idea of
what conversations
I wanted to encode into
the Dialogflow framework.
I had the lingo.
I knew the way this
was going to work.
So we kind of jumped in.
And there's me talking with Rez,
and we're going through this,
and we're getting excited with
how quickly and easily we're
able to build some
of this stuff.
But of course, I'd
recommend, like with
any architectural
design process, or even
your actual software
implementation process,
you actually do sit down
with a pen and paper
and work out what you want to
do first, rather than just jump
in.
Because you need to make sure
that you make some assumptions
that are the correct
ones at the beginning.
Because otherwise, you're
going to end up unpicking some
of the stuff you've done later.
So are your conversations
correct for Dialogflow
in the first place?
OK.
Let's say they are.
You want to make sure you know
who the target audience is
for your chatbot,
like any product.
And then, you want to work out,
for that target audience, what
are the number one things
that we're spending time
doing now that we
don't want to do,
or that we can do a better
job of doing by automating?
So what are your key use cases?
And then, you need
a persona, right?
So in finance,
generally speaking,
people are doing a
lot of work every day.
It's very transactional.
It's quick, it's fast.
There's not much
small talk, really.
And so you want this persona
to be quite efficient
so that you can move on and
do the next thing that you
need to do.
So then you want to sample--
you want to design things out,
you want to test, and that's
the green section here.
So spending more time
doing that at the beginning
is going to help you a lot
later on down the line.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
And actually, one thing
from that previous slide
that I found
particularly interesting
is it's very easy, when
you're building out
the conversation
and the intents,
to assume that other people will
ask it in the same kind of way.
Being from London and
working with a lot of folks
from the US, et cetera, I know
that to be very not true now.
And it's very useful to get
some intents up and running,
and then get colleagues-- and
I'd actually say colleagues
from different countries, if you
can-- to actually try it out.
It's amazing the different kind
of variations that you get.
And one thing we
didn't show you was
how easy it is to do
training with Dialogflow.
So you get one of
these sessions--
it's almost like a jam session.
You sit down and everyone
tries to fool the system.
You find different ways of
actually asking the questions,
and then use that to train it.
And when you're
doing the training,
make sure that part
of the training
hasn't exposed a different
branch of the conversation
that you need to build in.
So it's very easy
to start trying
to overload a single
branch of the conversation,
rather than saying, OK,
actually, the intent has now
changed, we should
create a separate intent
to cover that kind of flow.
The other one from that first
one is the tail latency.
So what you'll find is that
you'll very quickly get
the chatbot up and running,
in terms of the standard flow
of the conversation.
Spend just as much time on the
bits of the conversation that
might be broken, right?
So if the user goes
down the wrong path,
the context get
incorrectly set up.
Spend just as much time there.
Because a couple of negative
experiences from a user,
and then they're going
to be reluctant to use
the chatbot again.
JAMES TROMANS: Just
on the training,
I think one thing I should add
is when I started doing this,
at first, you're like, OK.
Chart me euro dollar,
show me this, plot that.
And you're kind of showing
a bunch of examples,
and you're thinking, I
could just write this myself
with regular expressions.
What's the big deal?
And that was how I came to
this, and I was like, mm.
But what you quickly realize
is, through the workflow
that Dialogflow gives you, you
can quickly tag, like, hey,
this is the intent.
This is the entities.
But you've given it maybe
half a dozen, or whatever--
3, 4, 5.
And someone then uses
the tool in a way
which you hadn't trained it on.
And that's when you
start to be like, ah,
that was my ah-ha
moment, when I was like,
oh, actually, it's going to
understand this thing that I
didn't train it on.
And subtly, and I think
quite importantly,
if you're into language,
understanding that something
plot me-- whatever
that might be--
and then the entities, you could
ask that in a different way.
You could ask that
like, eurodollar,
show me a chart of that.
And Dialogflow gets robust
to these types of things,
as long as you've
given a sensible amount
of seeded information.
And that was one
of the key things
that I really liked
about that the tool
that, at first, I
didn't quite get.
REZA ROKNI: Thanks, James.
And the other piece,
when you're drawing out
these conversations.
Draw out some flowcharts using
the tools that Dialogflow has,
in terms of like
slot filling, which
was where we asked
for currencies when
one wasn't given.
Now, context, which
we didn't show you,
allows you to store the
context of a conversation
as you branch.
I think it was very,
very useful to actually
just pencil these
things out, and then
go and build the intents.
What you'll probably find is,
as you're penciling these things
out, as well, you'll find some
branches that don't make sense,
and you'll fix them up.
So with that, some
final thoughts.
James?
JAMES TROMANS: Yeah.
So hopefully, you guys
have got a good feel
about how you can use Dialogflow
within existing applications,
also within existing
infrastructure,
depending on the company
that you're coming from.
And I think I'll loop this
back to the beginning, which
is what seeded this initial
idea, which we actually
haven't fully fleshed out yet.
But for us, because
we have so much data
and we are a large
bank, and we service
a lot of different
clients, we think
that one of our
unique benefits is
that we can bring the
right type of data
to the client when they need it.
And so, for me, I was
thinking about, OK,
what happens if both
an internal user comes
to a trader who is
very busy, and they're
managing their portfolio.
And that user wants
to say, to the trader,
why did the exchange
rate of this asset
just spike over the
last 15 minutes?
What caused that?
Now, we have all of
the trader information
that happened up to that point.
We have all the economic
event data up to that point.
We have all the market
data up to that point.
It's not beyond the
realms of possibility,
and we've been building this so
that you can programmatically
produce a natural language
response to that query that
draws on all of this
data, and frames it
in such a way that
is human readable,
and it's nice to read.
So we can say we're seeing a lot
of leveraged investors buying
because the economic
release that just happened
was weaker than we thought.
And we're now at
the 94th percentile
rank for the month for
this exchange rate.
And so we're seeing a lot of
momentum in that direction.
You could produce that
report programmatically
through the data that we have,
and you could imagine a user
asking for that, just
quickly on a chat, being
like, why did this happen?
You could respond
in chat in kind.
And so for me, where I
want to take this project,
is more down these lines.
I think Dialogflow
is great for FAQs.
It's great for just
the simple things
and, for sure, we'll be
looking at that, as well.
But I think there's a lot more
interesting, subtle things
that you can do,
which create a sort
of overall ecosystem of text.
And of course, there
are some clients
who just want everything over
API, and that's fine, too.
But for the people
that are in between,
this is a great way to service
many, many more clients
with high-quality content.
So we've covered
a lot of ground.
Hopefully, you got
a good feel for it.
But that's it for me.
REZA ROKNI: And
just to say, there
are some more sessions that are
available, running tomorrow.
And again, thank you very much
for spending some time with us
this morning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]